- One of your friends and co-stars,
on "The Flight Attendant"...
I love "The Flight Attendant".
I'm so excited about the second season.
- Thank you, thank you! (applause)
- So excited.
She really helped you
through everything, right?
- Yeah.
Zosia, yes.
- Thank you.
Zosia is my co-star and my best friend.
She helped me so much through season two.
She basically lived with me the
last few months of shooting.
We just moved in together.
I don't think I would have
gotten to work some days without her.
(chuckles)
- Oh, I have those friends.
Yeah.
- Yeah.
And I never thought I had to
depend on anyone like that before.
I really depended on her,
and she helped me through so much.
She would have days off,
and she would, oh, I'm gonna cry.
She would come to work on days
she didn't have to be there.
And come and have lunch with me.
And I'm like, "You have
your day off today."
She's like, "I'm coming in."
'Cause she heard I was
having a rough time,
and she would sit in my trailer.
She's the best.
I'm very lucky that I had her.
- Female friendships,
as far as I'm concerned
are my most healthy
relationships I feel like,
other than my family.
And they're so good for us
because I feel like we connect.
Even when I was married,
you connect in a different way
than you do with like your girlfriend.
- Totally different way.
- Yeah.
- It's totally different.
There's nothing like it.
- It's so good for us.
- I'm always promoting
that with my everyone.
I'm like, "You need to have
good girlfriends in your life."
It's so, so, so important.
- Yeah, you know what?
I don't even know if I trust a girl
that doesn't have a girlfriend.
- That's a little strange.
You gotta have a good girlfriend.
It says a lot about you.
- I know, someone was once told me,
"I don't really have girlfriends"
and I was like, "That's not shocking."
- Yeah, no, it's weird.
- I was like, "It's not shocking news."
- It's very clear (laughing).
- And we call each other out,
but we lift each other up.
It's like a really healthy... anyway.
- I totally agree.